for years musician Florian hilar has
collected private photos autographed
posters even clothing his museum is a
tribute to the punk band The Ramones but
it's also a tribute to Berlin bless the
Lord what brings the people in Berlin
together at the very specific spirit of
the city is that everyone has the
feeling they should contribute something
Stardust by Takata
Berlin is an inspiring city this could
also be seen in fashion many young
people like to mix old and new in the
district of Prenzlauer Berg
there are numerous vintage and
secondhand stores Florian Heilig
favorite place to shop is Paul's
Boutique the shoes and clothes are for
sale everything else is part of the
decoration
the sneaker collection alone includes
1,000 pairs winters the time to look for
a pair of shorts
if you tried them on
he likes it better here than in any
department store the Heon expended he
pillar don't find anything here probably
shot but chain stores but you also have
to have enough time to find your way
through things here like in a good
record shop you can't just look and pull
something out at random but you have to
search specifically for things knocking
there's nothing better than to have the
feeling of discovering something and
finding something for yourself
time for a change of scenery a history
lesson in the middle of Berlin is in
here and we see here a section of the
original Berlin wall with a hole that
people made in it
in 1989 people stood here with hammer
and chisel to get their own piece of the
Berlin wall the Ramones were here after
their concert in November 1989 and took
a piece of the wall back to New York New
York and on today this piece of the wall
is part of a memorial the topography of
Terror not only the wall on this site is
left over from a German dictatorship in
the Nazi era this was the site of the
main buildings of the SS paramilitary
and Gestapo secret police an exhibition
documents how the Nazis planned their
crimes
after the Second World War Berlin had to
start all over
he is enviable in detect nothing click
here we see Berlin right after the war a
devastated bombed out city you have to
find an orientation point to see where
you are and where things are today all
these gaps were left unfilled due to the
division of the city and came to life
again only after the wall came down it's
like it's heightened Stutz me conferred
Voronezh nothing more fight and that's
what's given this city the space and the
flexibility to allow things to develop
the IBM had when Dana Vollmer on the
mid-season and Vika Caen Florian's last
recommendation takes us to the Noi Cohen
district to a vegan crapper II where
there was a hair salon just a few months
ago there's now an eatery called
let it be
vegan cuisine contains no animal
products and is gaining ground in the
city
there are simple dishes such as crepes
sandwiches and cakes
he know my name daddy daddy I think
anyone who's visiting Berlin should
visit Noah come to check out the vegan
epicenter here you can find the right
thing for every taste and anyone who has
a craving for vegan crepes and
sandwiches should definitely come - let
it be let it be come for Florian hilar
Berlin is the greatest city there's
always something new here